in an emergency seconds can mean the
difference between life and death but in
many parts of the country time is lost
when the caller is using a cell phone
and the 911 can't easily determine their
location now a small start-up company is
quietly revolutionising the emergency
response system to address these flaws
Jamie yuccas has the story it can happen
in an instant is everybody out of the
water do you know well they're not there
screaming for people in the water every
day more than 600,000 people call 911
desperate need of help
yep the 911 falls short when it's needed
most because it was built some 70 years
ago for landlines today about 80% of
calls come from cell phones locating a
mobile phone is based on cell tower
triangulation if a phone can connect
with multiple towers a location can be
determined within an area of about
three-quarters of a mile it's something
we always just take for granted that
this system just works and minutes
seconds really matter in an emergency
Michael Martin learned firsthand how the
outdated infrastructure can impact a
crisis when he was mugged in New York
City about seven years ago the 9-1-1
could not pinpoint his exact location I
started out working in venture capital
and was just blown away by all the
different ways we were using technology
to better deliver alcohol or stream
music but when I needed an ambulance
it's just basically no ability to get
help so he launched a start-up called
rapid SOS and spent six years creating
technology that's transforming emergency
communication we were so fortunate that
this community would work with these
computer nerds on how can we solve this
problem 9-1-1 they were just the
operative one 22 the Emergency Response
Center in Los Angeles was among the
first to adopt rapid SOS now they locate
a cell phone caller within seconds if
somebody's in the middle of a domestic
violence and
it's sometimes hard to even call and
sometimes they can't speak so all they
can do is dial and leave an open line
and all you hear is arguing in the end
what we want is a location to send the
police to get help to them and this has
changed that yes definitely not one
emergency operator eight eight nine
the FCC estimates over ten thousand
lives a year could be saved if we could
just more accurately locate people in an
emergency
Michael Bach nears loves fishing from
his kayak near Clearwater Florida
but last month as he was pulling up
anchor the kayak turned over and his
legs became tangled and rope I was
stranded out there I couldn't get my
kayak flipped back over I tried it was
impossible and I was in total shock
water was only 56 degrees and at that
point I had to think of what to do
Botany airs keeps his phone in a
waterproof pouch so he called 911 says
rapid SOS saved his life sy heard 9-1-1
tone a helicopter my coordinates and
they knew exactly where to find me
partnering with companies like Apple
Google and uber allows rapid SOS to
offer their location data enhancement to
all emergency call centers for free it's
just hard to picture how intense this
job is until you've been there and
listened in on one of these calls the
new technology is now live in 911 s
covering more than 65 percent of the
population but that still leaves
millions of Americans at risk we just
want to make sure that every 9-1-1
center is aware this technology exists
it's free and it's ready today to help
you save those lives for CBS this
morning Saturday Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles Tony has a theory well I'm happy
that this has come along I mean ten
thousand lives a year and if they
deliver a car a burrito to your house
they should be to get an ambulance yeah
I think so it didn't that work that
these these people do these emergency
responders it's so important and they
need all the help they can get I mean
that the scenario the woman described
you know a lot of times you get a phone
call and the people don't even can't
even speak they're in the middle of
arguing or whatever so being able to get
a location immediately just changes the
whole game
total game changer